[Applause]
in sub-zero terrain
troops from nato's very high readiness
joint task force are training for the
coldest of conflicts
the soldiers are among the alliance's
first responders currently under french
command
that's the place we live we sleep and we
fight among them polish soldier private
piotr marcinac poland has now found
itself
on nato's eastern flank against a
possibly hostile enemy what does that
mean for you as a polish soldier i was
sure what i was signing for joining the
army but
of course it's it's difficult as a for
human human being but
we were we're just doing our job
russia's invasion of ukraine poses the
biggest threat to european security in a
generation several nato states are now
rushing to ramp up their defence
spending and germany europe's largest
nato country has reversed its position
on sending weapons into war zones in
order to help ukraine alliance top brass
fear russia's stop playing by
international norms time will tell
whether
whether the things that the russians are
doing in in ukraine
are war crimes or not
it is sometimes difficult to think that
it
is all an
uh especially if you hear that uh
now more than 30
medical facilities have been
hit the refugee stream and the fact that
people are not allowed to flee
even after after an agreement or when
they are fleeing they're still being
targeted those are all things that that
shouldn't happen
this week nato warned that russia's
accusations of ukraine storing
biological weapons could be used as a
pretext for chemical attacks these
french soldiers tasked with handling the
aftermath of a chemical attack are on
high alert
what seemed inconceivable only a few
weeks ago seems chillingly possible
if you think these cold weather
exercises are simply about nato
bolstering its eastern flank then think
again
in recent months russia has been
steadily reopening its cold war bases in
the arctic a region that has 30 percent
of the world's untapped natural gas and
13
of its oil supplies
as europe tries to wean itself off
russian energy supplies more countries
are turning to norway to make up for
possible shortfalls until the evasion of
ukraine began norway and russia had been
working together to explore arctic oil
fields but not anymore
his feared competing claims for natural
resources would put russia and nato on
another collision course the invasion of
ukraine has major consequences for
european security
nato chiefs say the alliance must be
primed to respond
barca al jazeera in central norway